what is King Charles III's first order
of business taking on a very different
Crown the Princess of Wales upstage
speaking about her broken marriage her
life and her future this is becoming
all-out war exploitative and mangling
people's reputations that's what royal
sources are reportedly calling season
five of the crown which centers on
Charles's failed marriage with Diana
shooting continues in the UK with
Elizabeth Debicki as die Prince Harry's
friend Dominic West is now the king with
the series set to drop November 9 a
headline claims the palace wants Netflix
to add a warning before the show calling
it a drama not a documentary
but it's back to business for the firm
the new Prince and Princess of Wales
William and Kate made their first
official visit to their namesake country
today A source tells E.T Wales is a
special place for the couple it's where
they lived as newlyweds and it's where
William had his first engagement with
his parents at the age of eight
the flag at Buckingham Palace is back at
full Mass the Queen's gravestone is on
display Charles's first official
portrait as King has been released and
new banknotes featuring his portrait
will be in circulation by the end of the
year people should expect the real me in
this and probably the me that they've
never gotten to know also getting back
to work Meghan Markle her archetypes
podcast returns next week after delaying
new episodes for the official morning
period despite that show of respect
we're told this move by Megan caught the
Queen off guard Elizabeth was quote
surprised that Megan picked a pure white
wedding dress given that Megan was a
divorcee
and there are new details about the
Queen's last days a source tells E.T her
beloved corgis were with her in her
final hours in her room to comfort the
queen
foreign